[MUSIC PLAYING]
I know, it's crazy,
I'm wearing shirts now.
Hey Marvel fans
Ryan Penagos, a.k.a.
Agent M, here with the VFX
supervisor of Marvel Studios'
Avengers Endgame Dan DeLeeuw.
How you doing, Dan?
Good, how are you?
Very well.
I would love to
talk about the Hulk.
One of my favorite
reveals in the movie
is when we see the
new Smart Hulk.
He's a very classy, he's
got great fashion sense,
wonderful glasses.
Where did you and the team
start to look at developing
this new look for Hulk?
Well, we started it with
a couple different ways.
We had, you know,
kind of, the look dev.
They started, kind
of, experimenting
with different ideas--
how much Ruffalo, how much Hulk.
And so it was making
sure that we could
have just enough of Ruffalo
there that, you know, you
believe him as a character and
help us to bring that character
to life by what we could do with
bringing the animation into it
and motion capture into it.
Mark doing the motion
capture and it seems
like he's just having a ball.
He's, like, ad-libbing and
even-- like, he's dabbing.
Yeah.
What is that like for you as
someone who's creating all this
and being able to express
this amazing CGI character
with someone like Mark?
It's that
partnership, I think,
is key when you get someone of
the caliber of Mark Ruffalo.
He could bring so much because
he knows the character's
journey through the films, you
know how brilliant of an actor
he is, and then suddenly
he's bringing that to you.
And then for the visual
effects side of it
you want to be in a place
that you have the artistry
and the technology
at a place that
can actually incorporate that
into the final visual effect.
His face is so elastic
and his big cheeks--
it's like you need to be able
to get all of that and, kind of,
one, to get you out
of the uncanny valley
and, two, just make-- you
know, realize that it's Mark.
And, kind of, some of
the first tests we did
and when we finally got all
of the software working,
it just-- it's like magic.
You know, you've
got him in the diner
and there's this one shot-- it's
my favorite shot in the film--
where he's, like--
you know, Hulk's there
eating a giant stack
of pancakes and eggs
and you've actually got the
digital character, you know,
talking with his
mouth full of food.
You know, it's hard enough
to get the lip sync to work
correctly, but
suddenly he's actually,
you know,
[MAKES GARBLED CHEWING NOISE]
around the food.
And it's, like, oh,
my God, it's working.
This is amazing.
I love that diner scene.
As I was rewatching actually
where Mark is in the suit--
the motion capture suit--
I just got fascinated
with the fact
that there was an actual
crepe and then I--
you know, you watch
the final version,
and then there's this digital
crepe, and Hulk's hand.
And I just find it fascinating
of how you and the team
put Hulk in this scene with
all these other characters
and how this all comes together.
The key to all this--
making all this work--
the biggest thing
you can do is make
the actor comfortable on set.
They're in this giant helmet
with a camera on the front
of it and this crazy outfit
that we use to be able to track
it with cameras without--
you know, a lot of times people
will try to do that just in,
like, a motion capture volume
that's separate from set.
And, if you can, you want
to be able to put them
on set with their
other actors, so they
can listen to each other
and play off each other.
And then you give them
things like the crepes
and the sausages, so that they
can actually feel like they're
that character in scene.
So, you know, it's a way to keep
the scene from becoming sterile
because a lot of times with
visual effects-- you know,
when you just got a giant
blue screen out there,
it's, kind of--
it'll take the actors out of it.
I want to talk
about the taco scene.
One, the internet loves them--
that Hulk giving
tacos to Scott scene.
I think it is wonderful.
It's so sweet.
And when you talk about,
you know, Mark taking Hulk
on this journey,
and the character,
and the way he's developed--
I also am just fascinated
by this massive CGI
character handing these
tiny little tacos.
I assume that was all VFX?
Yeah, it was all VFX effects.
We had, you know, Mark on set.
We had real tacos that
he could hand to Paul.
Sometimes you'll get lucky and
you can keep the real tacos,
sometimes you can't.
You know, with the
case with Hulk,
you know, his hand's so
much bigger than Mark--
we ended up replacing
them and, you know,
it ended up being this
really sweet moment.
When we're talking about the
way that the Hulk has evolved--
now, we see our Hulk going
back to the Battle of New York
and seeing his more
aggressive side out.
How do you, as the VFX
team, work with Mark
to actually express the--
the, sort of, reluctant Hulk.
If you look at the
different films--
you go from the first
Avengers, to Ultron,
to Ragnarok-- you
know, the Hulk model
changed throughout the films.
And so because we were
traveling back in time,
we actually just went
back and resurrected
the actual sculpt of Hulk
from the first Avengers
and started with that.
And then when we
started with Smart Hulk,
we knew he was going to be--
because of the merging
of Banner and Hulk,
he'd be a little
bit smaller, right?
So the Hulk himself he's
about eight foot, 8 foot
5-- you know, he'll
slouch a little bit.
If you compare him
to Thanos, he's
actually taller than Thanos
except when he's slouches.
So he's a little
shorter than Thanos.
So we made about 7 foot 5.
So we used the proportions
from the first Avengers
and then, kind of, started
manipulating from there
and, kind of, putting some
more of Banner's humanity
into the Hulk-- into his sculpt.
We got the first, kind of,
turntables back and on his face
you captured Mark,
you captured his face,
and then when everybody saw
it, they all thought, well,
he's really handsome, you know.
And it was like-- and
we kept getting it,
so it's like-- you
know, Hulk's got game,
maybe he's going to go on
dates over the five years.
I imagine that you have
a computer that is just,
like, Hulk and you have
sliders for, like, you know,
making him smaller, making them
larger, like, more handsome,
more handsome, more handsome,
and he's, like, you know,
hearts all around him and
everybody's, like, whoo--
I want that computer.
I love all those
little details and I'm
sure we're going
to see tons more
when Marvel Studios'
Avengers Endgame hits
digital and Blu-ray.
Thanks so much for
being here, Dan.
- Thank you.
- Appreciate it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]